at 22 he was a venture capitalist
raising from 500,000 to 15 million he
wants to solve the world's biggest
problems untapped human potential he's
got a giant bag of Doritos in front of
him all day long to remind him that he's
stronger than those Doritos he's Evan
Carmichael and here's our take on his
top ten rules of success volume 9
all right let's kick it off with rule
number one love the struggle you need to
learn to love struggle you need to learn
to tell yourself that the struggle is
the best because if you're not chasing
down difficult things you're living a
life so safe so inside your comfort zone
that you're never happy I had a woman
come out to my event last night here in
Milwaukee and I gave her some advice on
how to build their business and she said
wow that sounds so hard yeah teach
yourself that you're the kind of person
who does hard things I love hacks
I love shortcuts I love optimizing I
love it it's amazing it's the best and I
love doing difficult things otherwise
you stay inside your comfort zone and
you only do the things that you feel
safe to do and then you hate your life
if you're not pushing up against your
comfort zone if you're not stretching
further if you're not going into the
struggle you hate your life the people
who are the most fulfilled are the ones
who are off pushing the envelope doing
difficult things I look at this I broke
my neck in Denver right I broke my neck
I'll continue to tour we still had I
don't know five or six more stops that
we had to make almost a month of touring
you still had to go off into the tour I
cancelled one stop they made in a short
version in Kansas City and then I did
all the way through we're still going
full three hours I had to still make
videos write videos still have to go up
last week I was still suffering from a
concussion so I hit my head on on the on
the base board cut my head open
three staples in the back of my head
broke my neck broke my upper back got a
concussion still gonna make videos right
I still have to make videos I love it
because it's in the difficult times that
you show yourself what you're made of
when it's easy and you win you don't
care if you win every seconds
three-year-olds who cares but if you go
up and race against Huseyin both and he
beats you backwards on one leg you're
still pump because you're caught in the
race again so saint bolt the self pride
the self-respect the confidence the
growth comes from doing things that you
struggle with not from always doing the
easy thing you hate your life if you're
just doing the easy thing rule number
two
help your customers I think you need to
be your customers chief goal officer I
think if you want to win in business you
have to understand your customers you
become their chief goal officer if you
aren't accomplish your goals the best
way to get there is help your customers
accomplish their goals if you're helping
them you're solving problems guess what
you're gonna make money they're gonna
pay you to do it now you have to combine
what they want right you're the chief
goal officer this is what they want and
combine it with what you love doing can
you help them solve that problem are you
the person to solve it or do you want to
refer somebody else off to them to solve
that problem when you can mix those
things together the thing you absolutely
love doing with what the customer so
desperately wants that's when you start
to win rule number three don't chase
money chasing money makes you do stupid
things money is important it has to be
in your top five it just can't be number
one you're heroes the people that you
look up to the people that you want to
be like the ones who went off and change
the world a meet a lot of money in the
process they had a mission money was not
number one for them look at whoever you
look up to respect love admire your
heroes understand them look at their
story money's in there top five but it's
not number one and so when you go up
against somebody like that when you go
up against somebody who's chasing down
their purpose and you're coming into the
industry because you think it's a hot
opportunity for this year they're gonna
question you will always get crushed by
the person who loves the thing if for
you it's just an opportunity and so
that's why chasing money makes you do
stupid things you get into an industry
because you think it's gonna be a hot
chance for you but you're gonna lose
because you don't love it the people who
love it will always win and so
so much better for you to go off and
chase down something you love and make
money in the process of doing that thing
it's why the number one rule for success
that comes up the most consistently
across all the people that I profiled
across all different kinds of industries
and backgrounds is you have to love what
you do
rule number four be patient with the
results you're not in a big enough hurry
because you don't view patience and
impatience properly you were trained and
conditioned with the perspective that
does not serve you today we're gonna
break that we're gonna set you free so
you can start hitting your goals a lot
faster
most people are patient with themselves
but impatient with the results I'll stay
out of again you're patient with
yourself but you're impatient with the
results you want the results to happen
right away you're impatient like when am
I gonna get these results but you're
patient with yourself you'll give
yourself a break you'll let yourself
down like I'll do that tomorrow you're
patient with yourself but you're
impatient with the results I want you to
flip it this is the perspective shift
that if you understand and make in your
business your entire life will change
you need to flip it you want to be
patient with the results and impatient
with yourself you want to be patient
with the results and impatient with
yourself know that the results that
you're after will take time you're
chasing down big goals you're an
entrepreneur you want to do amazing
things it's gonna take some time for
that to happen but the impatience you
need to put on a daily basis is on
yourself did you do the most you can do
today and every single day to move a
little bit closer to achieving your
goals so look at my business an example
my next goal is to hit 10 million
subscribers on my main youtube channel
that's a big goal it's gonna take me a
while to get there right it's not gonna
happen tomorrow no matter how much work
I put in no matter what I do it's not
happening tomorrow it's gonna take some
time I get that I'm patient with that
and I'm insanely impatient with myself
it's like what can I do more today to
get me closer to that goal also if you
want to have more confidence check out
our 250 for confidence series in the
link below if you're doing work that you
love you're more likely to follow
through you're more likely to do it
because it doesn't feel like
because you love doing it surround
yourself with greatness if you want to
be more confident you need to surround
yourself with things that make you feel
confident find whatever the smallest
first step is and in the smallest next
that is and continue to build those
steps when you look back you'll have
realized that you made it's a pretty
significant progress rule number five
find your core values if you don't get
this right your business will fail it's
not just about what you love doing in
the skill sets you have it's about
having similar core values as the people
that you bring on board you need to know
what your who is you need to know what
you stand for as a human being you need
to know what your mission is and bring
people on board who have similar core
values this is where so many
entrepreneurs fail if you only do a
self-assessment and say well I'm good at
this I'm going to be the technician I'm
gonna be the artist I'm gonna be the
coder I'm gonna be the one doing all of
the actual work and I need to partner up
with somebody who's a business person
who's gonna be doing the deals in the
media and raising the capital talking to
investors and doing the sales pitches
it's not enough to say well I'm good at
this and you're good at this so let's
get together and that's what so many
people do that's why so many business
partnerships fail because you're just
looking at it on paper you just see well
they have the skill sets I don't have
great let's work together boom we're in
business
and often times entrepreneurs will then
say hey Walt let's do 50/50 right you're
bringing this I'm running there so here
we go 50/50 partnership and for those
who've been through it before you know
how much of a disaster that can be
because everything looks good on paper
but you can't make a decision just based
off of paper it's like going to a dating
web site and put it in your ideal person
and then decided to marry that person
without ever going on a date
it's about core values why do things
fall apart because you don't share the
same core values and a lot of times you
need to know what your own core value is
to start with so you figure out your one
word your most important core value
that's the starting point you have to
figure it out it may it will serve you
not just for your business but for any
relationship for life
this is what you stand for is a human
and then you want to attract people who
not just have the skillset in the desire
but the same core value because you know
what the skillset is actually easier to
teach than the core value to make
somebody change their beliefs I don't
know how to do it it's crazy it's it's
ridiculous to give somebody a new skill
set is way easier to teach rule number
six chase the hell yes decisions you
spend too much time focused on the small
decisions that don't actually move your
business forward instead of focusing on
the ones that you actually get pumped
for so look at my business I look at my
youtube channel my goal right now was I
want to get 10 million subscribers on my
main YouTube channel I'm excited I'm
pumped let's go do it I'm chasing it
down and I've got a list of ideas a
giant list of ideas and as people watch
my videos and I talk to my friends about
it they give me more ideas and the list
just keeps building is this something
that you can resonate with that list of
ideas just keeps growing and growing and
growing
I keep it in Evernote I don't know where
you write down your ideas the problem is
most of those ideas
they could be fantastic strategic ideas
that just makes total logical sense to
do those things but I look at them into
like yeah okay yeah hmm it's okay yeah
that's good we should do that yeah yeah
[Music]
if you're not emotionally attached to it
you won't have massive success doing it
it has to be a hell yes and so when my
tour came along the idea of doing a 23
City 90-day tour I don't have time for
it logically it makes no sense I don't
have time to do this it's crazy look at
this giant list of ideas I have to do
hell yes I want to do then and off we go
23 cities 90 days I just got back hey
back in my entrepreneur Lane setting
here for those of you who are oh gee
from my channel you have to chase the
hell yes decisions and stop getting
stuck in the men and okay land rule
number seven be strategic I think people
should quit way more than they actually
do you stayed in the business for too
long you stayed with an employee for too
long
you stayed in a relationship for too
long
should have quit on them years ago but
because you've tied your self-worth to
winning your pride prevents you from
quitting staying in something even if
you hate your life just staying in it
means that you don't have to admit to
yourself that you're a quitter and so
you stay but you're actually losing in
my first business was a software company
I struggled with this I was 19 I thought
I was gonna make it rich and be a super
successful entrepreneur and I sucked and
I struggled I was making $300 a month
and and I didn't know what to do I was
too embarrassed to tell my friends that
I had no money and I couldn't go out
with them and that the twenty bucks of
beats and beer was too expensive for me
and it took me to a rock-bottom moment
until I could actually be strategic and
realized that I needed to change what
happened was I told my partner that I
quit we were working long hours like
this is my entire life working on this
business crazy hours and just not
getting results
and so I'd finally had enough I felt
like a worthless human being and I
called my business partner said I'm out
like I have to go do something where I
feel like I can contribute to the world
somehow and so I told him I quit and
then I hung up the phone and I and I
cried I cried my face off and I woke up
the next day and said I can't quit on
this yet because I would regret it if I
did but I have to find another way to
stain like this is taking too much out
of me and so I asked myself who had done
this who had built the software coupling
before and I looked at Bill Gates and
how he started Microsoft and I used that
his strategies to help my company grow
and then we stood it away and then we
started to make money he started to get
some customers and clients and then when
she sold my business but I almost didn't
come back to it if I hadn't been
strategic in that moment and said okay I
can't quit because I'm gonna regret this
decision for the rest of my life if I
didn't step out of that emotional zone
just for a few seconds to realize I need
to keep going and look at who had done
this before I wouldn't be where I'm at
today rule number eight have a cause
having a cause will make you feel like a
superhero
it'll allow you to do things you never
thought you'd do
and give you the courage you'd never
thought you'd have all of your heroes
had a cause and if you want to stop
selling sugar water and change the world
it's time to find yours
I love the Steve Jobs story I'm a huge
fan of Steve I have his poster on my
wall as one of five people that look up
to on a daily basis but one of the
things that I really find most valuable
about having a cause is it can allow you
to have the courage to be the
evangelical person even if it's not
naturally who you are I look at Steve
Jobs and I see someone who is naturally
talented who's a great salesperson who
has the gift of gab who loves being in
the spotlight who is that person who
likes being up front and center and so
it's easy to go off and be that person
now you combine that with a cause and
you get a company like Apple but having
a cause can make you evangelical even if
you are introvert and shy and don't like
the spotlight I know because I'm talking
about myself I am an introvert I don't
like talking to people I don't talk to
the person next to me on the airplane
being in front of the camera makes me
nervous being in front of a giant
audience makes me shy had much rather be
at the back of a room than be the center
of attention one of the things they used
to fight the most with my agent about
was he would say that everything you
don't want to be famous that's a problem
like yeah I don't want to be famous it's
not about me it's about the cause and
recently it started to sink in that by
me becoming more famous I could spread
the message more but it's one of the
biggest things that we kept fighting
over because I don't crave the limelight
where a lot of people they absolutely
have to have it but when you have a car
that forces you to the front I make
videos because I want to help
entrepreneurs I make videos because I
struggled so much your purpose comes in
your pain I struggled somebody started
my business I want to make the path a
little bit easier for the next
generation of people coming through I'm
making videos and content and speeches
for the 19 year old version of myself
that needed to hear this stuff and so I
feel it's my responsibility it's my
obligation I have to do it and it forces
me out into stages that normally I would
say you're crazy I'm on this tour right
now right I gave up a quarter of my year
90 days they hit 23 cities and do the
thing that I'm most afraid to do which
is get up and potentially disappoint
people every four days by
doing another event and I kept going
even though I broke my neck I broke my
neck three weeks ago in Denver and and
we kept going I only canceled one event
completely and it just got up and kept
going and so having that cause feeling
like the work that you do is important
and meaningful is the whole thing rule
number nine do what makes you proud the
problem is you're not proud of yourself
you might post about some accomplishment
you've done on Facebook or Instagram but
when it's you by yourself
all alone deep down you're not actually
proud of yourself so why where does that
come from it's because you've taught
yourself that you set goals and you
don't consistently follow through so now
when you set a new goal for yourself you
don't believe that you're actually gonna
follow through and that continues to
cycle on and on and spirals down into
you not being proud of yourself we need
to change that today so it starts with
this when you set a goal you have to
follow through the only acceptable
reason for not following through is you
being proud of yourself are you proud of
the reason why you didn't follow through
so a couple examples when I started my
tour the very first stop the pre tour
stop was Boston I had a goal at that
time that I was gonna run 30 minutes of
cardio every day we drove the Boston I
drilled the whole way didn't sleep a
wink got in at 2:00 in the morning I
hadn't done my cardio what do we need to
do I need to do my cardio why because I
told myself I've committed to doing 30
minutes of cardio every single day the
cardio was the worst cardiovert I'm
barely moving right just kind of half
eyes closed
trying to struggle my way through the 30
minutes health-wise I burnt zero
calories it would have been better for
me to go to sleep
mentally though for the mindset I'm
pumped it's when it's hard and you do
the thing that you actually build your
self-respect
your self pride your self-love your
self-confidence when it's easy and you
win you could post a butter on Instagram
congratulations but you don't feel great
about yourself because it was easy but
when it's hard and you try that's when
you start building self respect self
accountability self pride that's where
it comes from and so
Boston I woke up the next day and I was
tired and I had a sluggish hard day
trying to get through it which was not
great for my body but mentally I'm
pumped like I did the thing when it was
difficult if I just went to bed at what
I had to ask myself am i proud of the
reason why I'm not doing this although
people would let me off the hook I'm
sure the people I went down with Ninon
my wife Danny my camera guy what is said
it's okay go to sleep it's 2:00 in the
morning you drove all the Suede's it's a
strange day it's not a typical day you
have every reason in the world not to do
it people will let you off the hook all
the time because they don't hold
themselves to high standards and then
they infect you with their lower
standards I would not have been proud of
myself if I didn't do my run even though
the results sucked it's the effort
that's where the pride comes from and
rule number 10 the last one just before
our very special bonus clip is just be
yourself just be yourself is one of the
most common pieces of advice that you
hear from successful people just be
yourself everyone else is taken just be
yourself
you're a unique snowflake yes amazing
but how how do I do it how do I find it
and once I find it how do I have the
confidence to actually live it how
give me the hell you're in luck I'm
gonna give you the three-step process on
how to actually find out who you are and
have the confidence to live it we're
gonna go through three steps who why
have your who your why your how you
figure that out you're set up for life
it's one of the most powerful exercises
you will ever do in your life let's dig
in number one your hoop your who is your
one word most important core value what
is your single most important core value
mine is belief when you understand what
you're saying for you're less likely to
be pulled in other people's directions
so quick tips on how to find it what's
your favorite movie of all time
mine is Seabiscuit it's about this horse
that's too small and a jockey too big
and a owner that has no money and they
find each other and they start winning a
whole bunch of races right what's your
favorite song of all time who's your
favorite teacher of all time and why and
if you look at all these things that you
have loved it wasn't because mrs. Jones
taught you math in grade 8 is because of
the characteristic there's a common
thread between all the things that
that make you happy that's your one word
that's your most important core value
when you figure that out now you can
live a life on purpose and bring those
things to you so for me believe I'm not
gonna make a video that's trashing
somebody I'm not gonna make a top 10
stupidest things that this person ever
said even though it might make me more
money even though it might bring me more
subscribers even though it might get me
more attention I don't want to do it
because it's anti belief and knowing
that knowing what I stand for then makes
it easy to put that shield up to say no
I don't care about your opinion I don't
care that you think I should go do that
thing I know what I stand for it gives
you a rock to stand on where most people
are sitting on quick st. figure out your
who except to is figure out your why
that's your purpose your purpose comes
from your pain think about the most
painful moment in your life your purpose
for life will be to help other people
who are currently experienced in that
pain to find somebody who is going
through the thing that caused you the
most pain in your life will lift you up
in and give you so much joy I can't
explain it
and your who and your why your one word
and your purpose are for life so for me
my why my purpose is helping
entrepreneurs because I struggled so
much as an entrepreneur because I turned
down huge jobs to make 300 bucks a month
and earned 30 percent of a company and I
hated my life like I felt worthless I
felt like I wasn't giving any value it
sucked I eventually made it through and
I want to help entrepreneurs because I
remember struggling so much as an
entrepreneur I don't want other people
to have to struggle the same way that I
struggled and so my one word is believe
I could believe in anybody I could
believe in lots of people everybody
needs believing in but I love helping
entrepreneurs more because that's where
I came from because that was my biggest
struggle it's my biggest pain and so
think about your most painful moment of
all time helping the people who are
currently experiencing the thing that
you went through is gonna be the thing
that will fill you up for life you're
who and you're why or for life they will
never change they're with you for life
and so it's worth going through that
thought experiment to find it because
most of America has no idea what they
stand for and what their purpose is sep
3 is your how now it's figuring out how
did you get through the thing that you
went through right I struggled as an
entrepreneur the thing that saved my
business was modeling Bill Gates how did
Bill Gates build a software company
that's what I had I had a software
company I wasn't working I copied Bill
Gates's strategies I plotted to my
business have my first sale shortly
after for thirteen and a half thousand
dollars I mean it seemed like a lot of
money but for me it was it was money it
was money was Bank like holy cow
something's actually working and so ever
since then that was when I was in
nineteen twenty years old ever since
then whenever I don't know what to do i
model success I modeled Bill Gates
success and put that to my company I had
success and so what have I done for the
past twenty years made made content made
videos look at my channel profiling
different successful entrepreneurs to
model their success the path that I use
to get out of the hole is the path that
then I teach the path that you use to
get out of the hole that you are in
becomes a path that you teach it's a
it's a system it's replicatable you
could teach other people how to do it
because a lot of the people who are
struggling with a thing that you
struggled with they never find their way
out you can help them by showing them
the path that you took and so you're who
you're why you're have when you figure
that out that's how you are yourself and
now you've got this amazing rock to
stand on when other people think you
should go do something else
you don't care it doesn't hit you it
bounces off you because you're confident
in yourself and so yes be yourself and
it's gonna come up over and over and
over and over again look at the top tens
look at the in spresso
look at all the videos look at the
interviews look at the people that you
look up to they're all gonna say just be
yourself by the how this is the process
if you go you're who figure out your why
figure out your have go through those
three steps and you're set up for life
and I'm so pumped to see the journey
that you go on and I've got a very
special bonus clip from Evan on how to
tilt the odds in your favor but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions it's time to go from
just watching the video to take an
action here we go number one how can you
enjoy the struggle number two how
patient are you when waiting for results
number three how can you believe in your
core values
just because you're following your
passion doesn't mean you're gonna make
money doing it but I don't think you
have to go work a job that you hate for
a decade until you earn the right to go
off and do the thing that you love I
think in a 2019 2020 environment we've
proven that it doesn't have to take an
insane amount of time for you to achieve
financial success the trick is to figure
out how can you combine that thing that
you love doing with something that
serves other people so that you can make
money doing it and it's not just a hobby
for you that fills your soul but I
believe that the fastest way to make a
lot of money is to be an entrepreneur
not to be an employee somewhere else and
if you want to be an entrepreneur the
lesson that comes up over and over and
over and over again from all the people
that I profile is you have to do the
thing that you love you have to follow
your passion otherwise think about it
you're going up against people who love
the thing that they're doing you are
competing with somebody who absolutely
loves this thing and for you it's just a
strategy you cannot lose the people who
love what they're doing will beat you
every single day of the week and so
instead of fighting an unfair fight you
want to tilt the odds in your favor and
do the thing that you love
if you want to see more Evan check out
his top 50 rules video in the link right
here continue to believe and we'll see
you there if you have to get motivated
every single day then you are in the
wrong business the people who win work
the hardest because they love what they
do